started out as a facebook group and an
online community that now has over a
million people on all of our social
media following
we've shipped out 890 000 boxes to
people's doors this year
in year eight tens of thousands of
shakes a day
and all done through a facebook
community an online social media group
so really excited to bring that to the
physical retail work and
retail world and vegas is our first
retail location
you can expect from 310 without a doubt
is um
a community that cares you're going to
find a staff here that's going to
focus on giving you the best service the
best experience and really focusing
around results 310 is a very results
oriented community so we're really
focused around our health and you're
going to find that
we are the community that cares and i
really suggest that if you want to know
about 310 just google 310
just go look at it and see what people
say and pictures say more than a
thousand words and there's a lot of
pictures online talking about 310. now
after a year that was so hard for
everybody i feel like people really
lacked a lot of nutrition and exercise
and things like that
um how important is it to kind of kick
start it at the very beginning of the
year when i'm sure people are
wanting a change well you're singing my
you're speaking my language you know
january 1st traditionally this is the
time we reset
you know this is a time when we get to
reset our health so there's no better
time to focus on your health now
to build your immunity to make sure that
you're not high risk and as we know
being overweight and unhealthy is one a
is a major
risk factor to what's going on with the
pandemic today so there's no better time
to make sure to take weight off there's
this thing going around called the coven
15.
everybody's gaining weight over these
last times because we don't have
the the the fun that we used to have
outside so we're turning to food and all
gaining weight so there's no better time
now
to change your mindset get healthy and
310 community online i would say join
our facebook group
check out the store and you're going to
find people who are really focused on
getting healthy
we're only what two days into the new
year we got a business opening in the
southwest is this
do you think it's kind of uh the trend
that's going to be happening
this year in the southwest valley well
here in the southwest we're at 215 in
rainbow this is really the new center of
the valley the center of the beltway
it's where so much is going on
new homes are coming up but also so many
small businesses have been able to
succeed in this area
from all across the spectrum so i think
there's a lot of activity here a lot of
optimism and reason to be hopeful here
in two days into the new year
for what's in store well this is all
about building community we want people
to have what they need
right as close as possible and this is
going to be a big part of that
but it's really important that we're
meeting the needs of all of our
residents and that means having
everything from robust health care to
robust food and
delivery services and options available
to them to really satisfy and meet the
needs of everybody here in clark county
throughout the rest of this year are
there any goals that you have for the
southwest valley whether it's business
development or
anything like that what are you really
focused on this year for your area
my focus is going to be to make sure
that we get our small businesses
back up and running those in a safe way
of course but in a way that's really
going to help them prosper
we've done a lot of work over the last
couple months during this pandemic to
help
make sure that small businesses have the
ppe they need
have the bridge gap funding to help get
them through this challenging time
but we're going to be there the entire
step of the way every step of the way
through clark county through our
business licensing operations and
through every lever we have available to
help small businesses
we'll be pulling them